-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Great to hear.
In that case,
let's get to the news.
First Lady Dr. Jill Biden
was heckled last week
outside of a Connecticut
ice cream shop,
but that's what you get
when you order rum raisin.
West Virginia Senator
Joe Manchin announced today
that he's tested positive
for the coronavirus.
Wow, he finally found something
he couldn't block.
Former President Trump and
former Vice President Mike Pence
held competing rallies on Friday
in Arizona
so the chants were either,
"Run, Mike, run!"
Or "Run, Mike! Run!"
[ Audience laughs ]
The annual Congressional
baseball game is scheduled
for Thursday evening
at Nationals Park,
and oh, look at this,
Josh Hawley
is stealing third base.
[ Audience laughs ]
Newark, New Jersey -- in 1950.
He stole a base in 1950.
There goes Hawley.
He's running down to third base.
Newark, New Jersey, set a record
yesterday after reaching
its fifth day straight of
temperatures over 100 degrees.
It was so hot in New Jersey,
you could bake a ziti
on the sidewalk.
[ Audience laughs ]
That's a joke Johnny Carson
could have told,
except he couldn't, because when
Carson had this job,
it wasn't 100 degrees
five days in a row!
[ Audience laughs ]
The New York Post
and The Wall Street Journal
each published an op ed
on Friday
denouncing former president
Trump for his role
in the Capitol attack,
and USA Today
denounced him in a Garfield.
Former Trump adviser
Steve Bannon was found guilty
last week of criminal contempt
of Congress and faces
up to two years in prison --
not including the two weeks
it takes to strip search him.
All right, take off that shirt,
and then that other shirt,
and then another one.
Jesus, the layers on this guy."
[ Audience laughs ]
And finally, the fast food chain
Subway will launch
a promotion this week that will
give customers free sandwiches
for a year if they get a tattoo
of the company's
Subway series logo
on their forearm.
Meanwhile, Arby's will give you
a sandwich if you just write
"meat" on your forehead
with a sharpie.
And that was a monologue,
everybody.